Jamie you guys went through all the
lawsuits and you looked throughout the
data and you found that a lot of the
deaths were linked to young kids 16 year
old 70 year olds who got their first car
and it wasn't quite clear what prompted
the accident and now that there is this
ignition switch debacle people are
connecting the dots that's right you
know it's a very traumatic incident when
your drive you're driving down the road
and your car were to suddenly shut off
there was in one of the cases there was
some testimony one of the engineers had
tried this himself he could make his car
shut off and he thought he did it in his
neighborhood and was able to pull it
over safely but that was somebody who'd
been driving longer than some of these
customers some of these drivers had even
been alive you know your people a lot of
pretty new drivers people in their teens
and they're driving especially then if
you add in other factors in some cases
there was drinking involved or it was a
right night and no but when you're you
know a teenager you're just much less
capable to respond to something that you
know tricky and predictable Jamie as you
know it's an interesting calculus with
correlation and causation was this just
because they were cheap cars and that's
what young kids buy yeah it's because
that's and let's be honest most of these
aren't the kids buying them these are
parents yeah you know these are
middle-class families who already have
maybe a pickup and a minivan and now
they've got a kid who's in high school
or going off to college and they're
gonna help them buy they want them to
have a new car so that it's safe and it
has technology yep it's small
fuel-efficient right well this
connection is a lot of them stuck around
as they stuck around as used cars they
were then they stayed you know as
entry-level cars their cars that you buy
for your kid Jamie as tragic as this all
is let's not forget that General Motors
got its bailout its federal bailout in
2009 which means the company doesn't
have to respond to legal claims filed
before 2009 so this is certainly
disturbing but the company is not
necessarily liable for things that
happened before then is that correct
that's right that's they're not liable
for the crashes that happened before
then they are liable for those that came
since GM has said they're going to
take care of their customers they don't
want to go beyond that that's sort of
you know Jeff Green has really pressed
them on this and it looks like their
intention is you know they they know
that they have to take care of these
people because it's the right thing to
do I would say you know it seems to me
that you know they're not putting down
their shield though they don't want to
just open up you know to everything but
they they they've indicated that they're
gonna accept some of that liability what
it will cost them you know what it will
cost the shareholders off the balance
sheet will hopefully would presumably be
a lot less than the you know cost in
public image of telling you know
families oh sorry we don't need to pay
you so we're not going to you know what
they could do that curious subtext here
Jamie looks like at least to the outside
world maybe you can comment on this the
GM effectively circling the wagons
saying it's going to pull its opel
division from china to effectively focus
opel on europe and maybe that means here
on the us what other signs do you have
that GM is circling the wagons and
trying to get its act together well I
wouldn't expect Opel to come to the u.s.
we what we're seeing is a carving up of
the global markets between Opel and
Chevrolet GM's decided to keep Opel and
and instead of having Chevy move into
Europe and try to take a low-end in the
market and Opel try to find a higher
position they're really just letting
Opel be Opel as a European brand try to
compete better against Volkswagen and
give it the opportunity to go down
market there right when you look at
China I mean the government in China
they know that these brands are all in
the same company I mean they won't even
let subaru invest in in China because
they see it as part of Toyota
so letting Opel back out of China gives
more Headroom for Chevy which is really
what they're playing it the Manchester
United sponsorship was not about winning
Chevy converts and the UK it was about
China right and that's where they really
want to play and that's where they're
really trying to grow